nos dicen queremos factorizar la
siguiente expresión y nos preguntan qué
patrón podemos usar para factorizar la
expresión
pueden ser enteros constantes o
expresiones de una sola variable vamos a
resolver esto juntos y veremos algunos
ejemplos más en donde les invitaré a que
pause en el vídeo cuando nos hablan de
patrones en realidad se refieren a ver
si algunas de éstas pueden formar un
patrón general que coincida con lo que
tenemos aquí y luego usar ese patrón
para factorizar la expresión en alguna
de estas formas que quiero decir con
esto
imaginemos algo como un más v al
cuadrado ya hemos elevado al cuadrado
binomios en el pasado por lo que esto va
a ser igual a un cuadrado más dos veces
el producto de estos dos términos 2 v
más v al cuadrado cuando vemos este
polinomio de aquí si nos fijamos con
cuidado vemos que tiene esta forma como
es que tiene esta forma bueno si
consideramos a 9 x a la octava potencia
como cuadrada
decir que es igual a 3x a la cuarta
noten que si elevamos esto al cuadrado
obtenemos 9 x a la octava por lo que
esto de aquí es un cuadrado y si decimos
que ye cuadrada es v cuadrada quiere
decir que v es igual a ye y esto de
enmedio tiene que ser igual a 2 por x v
es así así multiplicó por v es igual a
13 x a la cuarta jeff y si multiplicamos
esto por 2 queda 6x a la cuarta y por lo
que esto de aquí es 2 v noten que este
polinomio de grado mayor puede
expresarse con este patrón lo que
significa que podemos factorizar lo así
por lo que cuando nos preguntan qué
patrón puede usarse para factorizar esta
expresión pues yo usaría un más v al
cuadrado que es la opción a hagamos unos
ejemplos más
aquí nos preguntan lo mismo pero nos dan
una expresión diferente y nos preguntan
qué patrón podemos usar para factorizar
la expresión tenemos estos 3
por lo que parece que podríamos usar
esta opción ya que parece un cuadrado
perfecto vamos a ver si funciona si esto
es un cuadrado entonces es igual a 2 x a
la tercera potencia y si esto es v
cuadrada entonces v es igual a 5 ahora
esto es igual a 2 por 1 por v
veamos 2 x v es igual a no va a tener
una y en él por lo que esto no es igual
a 2 v así que no coincide con el patrón
de cuadrado perfecto por lo que
descartamos esta opción estas dos son un
tipo de cuadrado perfecto pero uno suma
v y el otro resta v en la opción b si
multiplicamos esto va a ser igual a una
diferencia de cuadrados que ya hemos
visto antes es cuadrada menos v cuadrada
lo que no da un polinomio de tres
términos así que descartamos esta opción
yo elijo la opción que dice no podemos
usar alguno de los patrones hagamos otro
ejemplo más
los invito a que pausa en el vídeo y
traten de resolver este problema por su
cuenta es la misma idea quieren
factorizar esta expresión y en este caso
tenemos dos términos ambos lucen como si
fueran el cuadrado de algo de hecho
parecería una diferencia de cuadrados
esto me hace pensar que este es el
patrón que buscamos pero vamos a ver si
funciona recuerden que un más v por un
menos v es igual a uno cuadrada menos v
cuadrada si esto es igual a cuadrada
entonces es igual a 6x cuadrada
esto funciona y si esto es igual a v
cuadrada entonces v es igual a ye más 3
por lo que esto cumple con el patrón de
aquí y como solo nos preguntan qué
patrón podemos usar no nos piden que
hagamos la factorización elegimos esta
opción pero ya que identificamos el
patrón es muy sencillo factorizar lo
porque si decimos que esto lo factor
izamos como un más v por un menos v
entonces un más
es igual aunque es 6x cuadrada más v que
es igual a más 3 x 1 - v es 6x cuadrada
menos v que podemos escribir menos ye
más 3 o podemos distribuir el signo
negativo de cualquier forma esto hará
que quede más claro lo que acabamos de
hacer usamos este patrón para factorizar
este polinomio con grado mayor que
esencialmente es una diferencia de
cuadrados
hagamos un último ejemplo aquí de nuevo
queremos factorizar una expresión que
patrón podemos usar pausa en el vídeo
muy bien aquí hay dos términos por lo
que podría ser una diferencia de
cuadrados si decimos que es igual a 7
esto será cuadrada pero que podemos
elevar al cuadrado para tener 10 x a la
tercera potencia
recuerden que queremos tener exponentes
enteros aquí y la raíz cuadrada de 10 x
a la tercera potencia es algo complicada
es la raíz cuadrada de 10
la raíz cuadrada de x a la tercera
potencia lo que no nos va a dar un
exponente entero por lo que parece que
no podemos expresar esto como v cuadrada
así que elijo la opción no podemos usar
alguno de los patrones y terminamos